geordan woods makes her first public
appearance since her Tristan Thompson
cheating scandal guys the Kardashian
drama continues after kylie jenner's
bestie was reportedly seen making out
with sister Chloe's ex Jordan spoke out
for the first time Thursday night at the
launch of her new I'll or false lash
line the model rocked satin pants and a
draped top as she took to the stage
saying thank you guys for coming out and
supporting me through everything that's
going on it's been real and I lore has
been super real with a project I've been
working on for over nine months right
now now sir stills et the 21 year old
model remained low-key at the West
Hollywood event quote Jordan was hiding
in the back area majority of the time
until it was her time to talk and thank
the people that showed up
we're told 150 guests were expected to
attend but only 20 guests showed up a
source previously told et that Jordan is
devastated and can't believe how her
entire world has flipped upside down so
fast our source adds she knows making
out with Tristan was wrong
[Music]
so so far all the Kardashian sisters
Khloe Kim Kourtney have unfollowed
Jordan she still remains on Kylie's
friends list but the former besties no
longer lived together hey guys it's
Kylie and Jordan here and get this guy's
the Kylie cosmetic Geordie lip kit the
prices would cut in half and it's sold
out on site so apparently everyone was
into that sale that was a savage but
awesome move I respect it and in case
you've been sleeping under a rock the
last few days here's what went down on
Tuesday a source told et that Chloe and
Tristan split after two years of dating
because of ongoing quote trust issues
those trust issues well that same day
the 34 year old reality star commented
on a Hollywood unlocked Instagram post
claiming Tristan recently cheated on her
with Jordan now in the post the
Hollywood unlock founder Jason Lee
claims the rumors about the two hooking
up our truth one of my writers was there
and Tristan you took everybody's phone
but you let them stay Jordan came in guy
was smoking who cuz she was all up in
your lap you was all over her touchy
feely and you let the girl spend the
night to 7:00 in the morning now that
happened that's a fact and I don't want
to hear nobody trolling Chloe talking
about you it's a Chloe it's a Kardashian
curse there's Chloe's father's that know
if it yeah Chloe commented on the post
with shouting emojis and her bestie
Malika also commented writing strong
facts we all need a rider like Malika
heck I love me some Malika but then
Tristan tweeted quote fake news after
the reports broke of his and Chloe's
breakup he then quickly deleted it and
Courtney we haven't heard from him since
oh my god so much drama now all this
drama comes after more than two years of
dating and ten months after Tristan made
headlines when he reportedly cheated on
her with multiple women while she was
pregnant with their daughter true Chloe
gave birth to true last April just days
after the report broke and the two
eventually reconciled
yeah and now a source tells ET quote she
has to be strong for herself and true
everyone is extremely disappointed and
as we can imagine
this is a really sad story so sad of
course as this story continues to
develop we will have the latest so be
sure to subscribe to all things ET and
in the meantime I'm at Halle underscore
Stephens and I met Courtney underscore
teza know bye for now guys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]